foreign
marriage counseling is pretty cool
because we voiced our needs did they
start with I need you to stop having sex
with other people that aren't me we were
talking about me selling my house moving
in with him and he made the comment he
would keep the house in his name in case
I cheated again he would kick me out
your marriage is over
[Music]
yo yo yo what up this is John with Dr
John deloney's show
so glad you're joining us we are back
from break and the show's been coming
out so you wouldn't know any different
but uh it is good to see everybody back
hey before we get going Kelly what in
the world dude so we did this whole
thing uh I don't remember when it would
when this is gonna be coming out
relative to to that but let's talk about
how things have been crazy in our lives
and then and then God said hold my beer
what so
what happened
so you know my daughter was in the
hospital after Thanksgiving right and
then I lost my mom yes and then we
thought that was a lot
it comes in threes yeah and then um
Christmas Eve we went to Christmas Eve
service and we came home and our house
flooded
um and it is a total loss of the bottom
floor
for those of you listening we had these
crazy ice storms it was freezing and you
have a sprinkler system in your house
yeah so the town we live in is a fairly
small town and had um up until a couple
years ago only had a volunteer fire
department so any house built before
then had sprinkler systems that no one
knows anything about the builders don't
know about them no one knows anything
about them and it bested they work yeah
they do
um so yeah it uh the entire bottle floor
of the house our bedrooms the kitchen
everything is a complete loss
um like subfloor the HVAC system got wet
and has to be everything
so we are in a hotel right now and
moving to a rental home for probably
four to six months
well I want you to know that I'm wearing
uh like a a bunch of religious symbols
underneath my shirt
and and
garlic around my neck and you're not
allowed near me dude I'm sorry man
thanks I heard about that on Christmas I
granted for Christmas I had no idea I
got a text from you like hey do you have
a contractor I was like oh Kelly's gonna
make have a deck or something I didn't
realize you were homeless yeah well we
got a hotel it's lovely with two
teenagers and a dog it's it's not no
it's not too teenagers in a dog
oh my gosh well I'm glad to see you I'm
glad to be back it's it's good to have
some something somewhat normal
because everything's so upside down
right now so when when this is your new
normal then we got a problem but it is
oh man all right let's go to Kelly and
up Kelly not you Kelly not me I swear
the other Kelly in Rochester New York
what's up Kelly
Dr deloney how are you I'm good how are
you
all right something must be wrong with
having the name Kelly because my furnace
went my hot water heater went and I
needed new tires
good grief man your furnace and your hot
water
yeah my furnace hot water heater and my
tires which it was like three degrees
like a couple weeks ago so I was worried
about my pipes freezing and
yeah it's no bueno man you got it worked
out
what's that you got it worked out
yeah good good good good all right so
what's up how can I help
yeah so uh my question is do I wait for
my husband to make a decision regarding
the future of our marriage or do I call
it quits
tell me more
yeah
so we dated for four years and we've
been married for six years uh we have a
six-year-old daughter okay just a little
bit of background uh in April 2021 I had
an affair uh he discovered this via text
uh he moved out uh we're still currently
separated but that's kind of a long
story
um I continue to see the new guy for a
year and then broke things off with him
so this wasn't just a hookup this is
like you you found somebody new
right what did this dude uh just this is
an aside what did this but it will loop
back around what did this person bring
you
um you've talked about that high and
feeling alive
um that was one thing
um I was uh
uh shoot sorry
um he paid attention to me
um validated me
um Mutual interests
we worked together which talked about
that a lot
um
so so your husband finds out
um he steps away you continue this
relationship
um and then it eventually breaks up how
y'all are still talking you and your
husband y'all never got divorced
right uh we were looking to file and
then kind of the rest of the story is he
was seeing someone else as well during
um that year like that I was and then we
both around the same time it was kind of
weird
um stopped seeing other people and now
we're trying to rekindle our marriage
um uh we went to marriage counseling he
initiated that and then I started going
to like one-on-one counseling through
better help and I'm still doing that and
then at marriage counseling it was
pretty cool because
we voiced our needs
um
which was kind of a long process
um did they start just just as an aside
did they start with
um I need you to stop having sex with
other people that aren't me
was that one of them uh no
well I mean it wasn't I mean we got into
the entire Story entire and guess what
I'm just wondering if that was because
if I'm in your if either one of your
shoes that would have been like my
second or third need probably top three
yeah I mean it wasn't yeah it wasn't
said as directly sorry it caught me off
guards but uh yes all right yes
so um so you're in marriage counseling
and it's clearly not going well so fast
forward to now
is he just falling off the map
exactly yeah um are you still living
apart
we are
um part of that is
uh we were talking about me selling my
house moving in with him and he made the
comment at marriage counseling that uh
he would keep the house in his name in
case I cheated again he would kick me
out yeah this like like your your
marriage is over
it's over
it's it's it's done and now
he sounds like he's unable to
to say it's over and so he's just gonna
let it run out of air I run out of gas
and when that happens it's very hard to
be
to to make rational adult decisions when
you resent each other and the longer
this thing just gets suffocated or just
runs out of gas
um and the cars just driving I mean just
rolling down the road it's not even
driving anymore uh man the Messier your
co-parenting gets the Messier decisions
you stop you start you stop not liking
each other and you start hating each
other
and tell me I'm wrong
no you're right I mean it sounds it
sounds oh yeah is he pulling back and
and withdrawn
yes and he's actually started I uh
discovered text messages that well I
didn't see them but he was texting the
girl he was with prior
um and I straight up asked him if he was
interested in her and he said no but
when I asked him about us if you want to
still be with me uh he said I don't know
I can't seem to get over what you did
yeah that's fair and so I here's the
deal you all need to go out to a
grown-up lunch or grown-up breakfast
and call it because here's the deal
you've got you've got a kid who's
absorbing all of this
right and
um
y'all are being cruel to her you're
being cruel to your each other
don't you think
yeah at some point and neither of you
want to you don't want to have been the
person who cheated and ruined your
marriage you don't want that right
um your husband doesn't want to have
been a guy that got cheated on
and y'all don't want to your daughter to
grow up in a divorce household you don't
want all these things yet here we are
and so this the sooner you can own
reality and acknowledge reality and then
begin to live with that understanding
the the
faster people will heal and the better
chances you'll have of being acting like
mature adults down the road yeah that
becomes does that make sense
yeah
so somebody's got to call it
okay
and if you sit down and say I'm asking
you to make a decision right now are we
done
um
and if he says well I still I don't know
it you need to have a decision
okay and if you get in this well I'm not
doing it well you're I'm not doing it I
mean come on man we got to be grown-ups
at this point you gotta you got a kid
right right and you'll have to make
decisions with what comes next
um it sounds like he's called it quits
he just hasn't said it out loud yet
right
okay I'm sorry
thank you yeah are you at a place where
you've forgiven yourself
um
working on it okay some days are better
than others yeah it'll take a season
and he's not blameless either
yeah
what have you learned in this situation
uh
take care of myself because
I'm used to
you know putting other people first and
then I realize I have needs and then I
make
for decisions so more of a balance
I think if you were to be honest about
your needs and have the courage to voice
them as you need them not wait till they
all pile up and then oh yeah they
definitely pile up that makes it and
becomes insurmountable and then some
sweet talking dude who just wants to
hook up with you at work
um
is able to
cut your values off at the roots right
right
yeah your values are worth being spoken
out loud
I hope you'll take that with you
yeah is that fair
yep the end of this even though it feels
like it's yellow I mean you all been
separated what a year now two years
or I guess a year and a half
yeah a year and a half yep okay
um
the finality will feel like a death
it will hit you harder than you think
it's going to
okay because there's part of you that
thinks I've been living with this I've
we've kind of been practicing being
divorced right and kid going back and
forth and all that it will be a whole
other layer when this thing is finalized
or when somebody says
I'm gonna do this let's do a no fault
divorce so it's not drama we're not
causing problems we're not splitting up
everything I'm not gonna sue you or
whatever we're going to be adults about
this we're gonna have a no fault and
we're gonna sign it up and we're gonna
then be great co-parents
um
and we're not going to give all of our
money to attorneys and when the moment
you do that it's gonna be heavy
and y'all both might sit there and weep
at the at the lunch table right
is it fair
yeah and here's what I want you to also
do this I want you to have just in case
just in case
you sit down for breakfast or lunch and
you say hey are we done
and he looks at you and says absolutely
not
it's 2023 I'm Coming Out Swinging for my
new Merit for my marriage we're gonna
make it new I'm not giving up on this
thing I'm all in I want you to have a
list of things five things ten things
here's what I need from you moving
forward we have to live in the same
house we got to share bank account you
got to be all in you got to put both
feet in this thing I'm going to put both
feet in this thing and that means you
can get hurt again and I can get hurt
again
but that's the only way we can go
forward
you tell me what you need
I'll open up all my text messages I
won't text another person I'm not
married to I I like whatever we need to
do
I have your list just in case
but it sounds like this thing is over it
needs somebody who's an adult to say all
right what are we going to do next
just about owning reality
I'm sorry that you're here
I hoped it 2023 is a year of healing for
you
healing always starts with telling the
truth own a reality and asking that one
terrifying question
what are we gonna do next
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we're back let's go to Frank
in Pittsburgh what's up Frank
how you doing John thanks for taking my
call and thanks for everything you guys
doing good you got it my brother what's
up dude how can I help my question is I
got I had a baby just under two months
ago okay congratulations boy or girl
thank you boy all right little little
Joseph little Joseph
and now it's time for his his shots to
come up because his vaccines and all
that and I'm struggling trying to
trust where the CDC and all that where
where the the mistrust with covid came
now I'm struggling to to trust where the
old stuff you know I'm questioning
everything of course when you ask a
question if the doctor shut you down and
say you know it's safe just do it yeah
well do I know it's safe do I what do I
do you know do I do I listen to them or
you know I'm not an anti-vaxxer by any
means but I'm
but the whole thing got sideways yeah
the whole thing goes sideways I I've uh
I've told some of my closest friends I
think I think this was a hundred year I
maybe even said on the show I think this
was a hundred year setback
for for so we lost trust in our churches
we lost trust in our educational
institutions we lost trust in medicine
and those are pillars that prop up a
civilization and there's going to be a
long
Hard Road back to trust and
re-establishing Trust
um so I'm gonna
I'm not a vaccine expert okay
and
I am though gonna tell you how I make
these kind of decisions I'll give you a
matrix okay okay or not really not
really Matrix that's that's not right
I'm gonna give you a framework for how I
make these decisions okay okay and then
I'll tell you I'll give you like the the
nitty-gritty what I think okay which
that might buy you a cup of coffee
um if the copy is free and it's like you
know I mean so
um
big picture
there's this
um a terrible human being and you've if
you've listened to show enough you know
that I rarely say that okay I think
people are flawed they screw up we all
do and then we all have roads to
Redemption there's a terrible human
being his name is uh Andrew Wakefield
he is the fraudulent scientist
Absolute Total fraud
who came up with this bull crap
connection between the MMR vaccines and
autism
absolute fake data lied about the whole
thing and then spread it out and then
just went on a on a campaign essentially
him and an attorney there's a fantastic
book by Brian dear
um it's like The Man Who tricked uh
Doctor Who fooled the world
um it's it's just disturbing okay so we
have this emergence
um recently of this anti-vaxing stuff I
can't express it enough how nonsensical
it is and here's where it's evil there
are
countless parents who have autism who
think they did something wrong to their
kid
that's why this dude is evil and that
planted these seeds of doubt and all of
us I've got two little kids right and so
I start questioning like when the I call
her the nurse of death when you have
this sweet little two-year-old or two
month old and then this sweet nurse
comes in and just pulls these these
these these shots out and Jabs this
little I mean that's a whole other day
of other story okay so I want to say
this like unequivocally this is not me
like I'm making a stand no I just look
at data just pure numbers vaccines have
saved millions and millions and millions
and millions of Lives full stop period
end of sentence okay and
covid got politicized in sideways in the
covert vaccine became a nightmare
yes okay
and I am right there with you I'm right
there with you so as a new dad you're
right to be nervous like what do I do
man do I do that like you are right on
with every other dad me included okay
yep and here is the framework by which I
make these decisions this is how I make
medical decisions this is how I make
financial decisions this is how I make
mechanic decisions
number one I have one two three four
five people that work in that field that
I trust
okay now
I'm privileged in that I've worked in
universities forever I know I I can call
research scientists in my cell phone
number okay I'm in my cell phone so not
everybody's got that
um and here's the here's the question
that shifted for me about a decade ago I
do not ask people what they think
I worked at a law school and there was
some of the most Brilliant Minds in the
world and those they were legal Scholars
they were professors of law so they were
trained over years and years and years
to find arguments and exploit holes and
arguments they were Masters at it okay
and I could ask him what do you think
about something and they could spend me
an hour-long detail about it
but then I would see their kids and I
was like well your kids doing that
like do you what do you think about
organic cotton and they'd be like well I
think organic cotton is this and this
and they would give me all this data
about the fields and about Roundup and
about all this stuff then I'd see their
kids wearing cotton cotton shirts and
they'd be like oh you think this but you
believe this
yes and so I quit asking what do you
think I do not ask that question anymore
I only ask this question what are you
doing with your kids
I asked my doctor that
I ask my friends that I ask my finance
person that I told my finance person I
want my portfolio to exactly match yours
and he was like he's a close friend he's
like well you know I was like no no I
want to exactly match yours and he's
like you got it
and because if you trusted enough for
yours you're not gonna sell me some
product I want it to look just like
yours same with a car hey which car do
you think is good
well I'm I like this one but on what car
did you buy for you and your family well
we bought that one well that's what you
believe then that makes sense so with my
doctors I have asked them point blank
what did you do with your kids
and if they gave this kid that vaccine
then it's safe enough for their kid then
I don't know enough other than what the
news tells me in some stupid YouTube
videos which
should not exist so I'm going to ask the
people in the field what are you doing
with your children and that's gonna be
that's gonna be my God you see what I'm
saying yes and that has given me
a lot of peace
yep okay
and so I've given I've given my kids not
all the vaccines but I have given my
kids MMR I've given them HPV my my
oldest like I've given them those things
um and there's a few vaccines that I
didn't give
because I sat down with my doctor and we
looked at the data and my doctor happens
to be a super nerd and he loves those
kind of questions I have a gut reaction
to professionals who don't like
questions
that's the the pickle I'm in is is my
pediatrician now
the practice they're in there anytime
you ask a question that's that's oh no
that's not going to happen well how do
you know how do you where's the data
where's the where do you how do you know
I mean do you
and then they they just they more blow
it off than answer the question right
and I'm fortunate
um Gus Vickery my doctor uh he he'll
he'll email me the study
and I was challenging him on something
he sent me two or three studies and I
was like well you're right and so not
every doctor can do that
um and not every doctor will do that
here's what I would love you to get in
the habit of doing and this is gonna
this is gonna be when you have to talk
to a third grade teacher this is going
to be when you talk to a middle school
coach when you whatever the theater
teacher
is sitting down and saying hey can you
explain this to me how this works
okay um and take the humble
um submission approach not the I was
watching this YouTube video and I
Googled it and I think it's because the
doctors get that all day long
yes but if you said Hey sir I feel like
you're blowing me off can I just ask you
like this is the most important this
person in my life is my little baby
I don't understand I'm getting a lot of
conflicting advice can you point me to
some data
and you can go from there and if they
say we don't do that then I would be on
the lookout for a new pediatrician and I
know that's a what is my insurance going
to take and it's going to take me a year
and all that I get that and that stinks
and it might not be this time but it
might be next time but
um that's where I would head out I just
might from my mechanic hey why are we
doing this particular thing and why are
we doing that I want people to explain
stuff to me and I and that's not out of
bounds if I'm paying you
exactly
yep
you're not crazy
um and you're a good dad here let me
leave you with this I'll leave you this
okay the mark of a wise person is
somebody who can hold
different
um data points in either hand and not go
mad
okay still make a wise choice
and so in the one hand we have to hold
that vaccines have saved millions and
millions of lives and if you're like I
don't think so
I promise my garden is bigger than yours
and my family eats organic I'm all into
all the conspiracies I'm just looking at
the data okay and then on the other hand
the coven vaccine turned into a absolute
Quagmire
okay I've got to hold both of those
and then look at my two two-month-old
and the Doctor Who wants to give them
their MMR shots round one
and say did you give these shots to your
kids because I'm just nervous about
vaccines now with all the drama
um did you give these to yours and if
they look at you and say I'm not telling
you that information then say I'm I
appreciate your time I'm gonna go find
me another doctor
99 of the time they will say yeah I did
I'll leave you I think I've told this on
the show
my uh
when my uh daughter was born we had an
amazing uh the greatest OB GYN ever
she's just stunning she was ahead of the
clinic at the university hospital where
my daughter was born she was just
amazing and I worked at the at the
University in another another college
and so we would I could email back and
forth just because we were in the
internal system and so I would ask this
kind of question and this question and
that question I was always asking all
these questions about MTHFR and all
these things
and then one day we're just doing a
routine checkup and I had just read this
thing about DEET how DEET was a
neurotoxin was going to kill us all blah
blah
yeah Deaton bug spray and we were
walking out of the OB GYN
of the you know the baby checkup and I
turned her name was Dr Phi Jennifer
fudge she's extraordinary I looked at
her and said hey
real quick
you put bug spray on your kids
and she smiled real big she knew she's
like yes John deed is not good for it's
not great
and I'm way more worried about other
things so yes I I spray bug spray on my
kids and I was like that's all I need to
know there's not one thing on a YouTube
video that I'm Gonna Learn that's gonna
be more value to me than a brilliant
research medical doctor and the way she
treats your own kids and so that that
became the litmus test for me
um I'm gonna ask you what do you do with
your kids what are you doing with your
money with your cars with your home are
you buying a house right now are you
waiting oh it's all coming down you
shouldn't buy a house why you buy one
why'd you buy one last month I mean it's
it's fine
what are you doing
with your most most important loves what
are you doing with your most important
assets that's where I'm going to follow
not just some I think that hey by the
way Frank you're a great dad good for
you for asking these hard questions good
for you for caring about
um the things that go in and out of your
um thank you for thinking caring about
your kid and their medical decisions
their nutrition decisions all that
you're a good man we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor better help
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is life
changing stuff but I'll be honest it's
not easy these are new skills that we
all have to learn and therapy is a great
place to practice these new skills and
that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go to Julie oh right
down the street in Nashville Tennessee
what's up
Hi how are you I'm good what are you
doing
well I'm hanging out in my car talking
to you
I'm I Hey listen in 2023 I'm trying to
be more mature and there was like three
jokes that I was about to make that I
did not make because I'm trying to be
more grown up so
I want all of America to know all 19
listeners uh uh I'm growing up okay so
Julie you're in your car chatting with
me what's up
well I'm calling to ask your opinion um
we're thinking about putting our
daughter into a private school but we
are middle class this is an elite
private school
um and how do we cope with
um or how do we help her cope with
feeling different from other kids and
will it be um more damaging to her to
attend this school or to go to public
school after we have to move to
Pennsylvania to
um try to get her a better education in
a public school Julie
I've already taken a vaccine call on
this show now you're giving me the
public school private school call
yes Kelly they're trying to cancel us on
the first episode all right Julie
um well here's the deal I promised on
the show I would never lie that was like
one of my core tenants when I took this
show uh I mean when I decided to do this
and so I'm just going to tell you the
truth as best as I know it and then I'll
tell you about my own kids and then
we'll go from there is that cool
yes okay let me ask a few questions
first why
how number one how old is your kid
um almost eleven okay okay why are you
worried about public schools
or why why a public school
I'm sorry why why a private school yeah
oh okay so she's already been in private
school through Elementary School okay
um yeah
Point um we're looking at going into
middle school and we're wondering if
that's something we should continue with
or if we should go on to public school
but this is not the place for public
school not where we live
um the schools are not great here and I
it's my responsibility to provide her
with the best education that we possibly
can
so what
um
hmm
what makes the schools not great
I think that the academics they're just
not up to par
um I have a relative who taught in the
schools here he'll say yeah they're okay
okay
um there are no advanced classes at all
no AP courses no extra
enrichment for kids that would benefit
from that there's just nothing and then
I have talked to a few
um students who graduated from the
school near us and they said they didn't
feel prepared for college at all okay
and they did well in high school
um
so you're thinking about moving or
thinking about mortgaging
yeah mortgaging your souls to pay for
private schools
is there a little bit where
like I've had a really crummy car a
bunch in my life actually and the car is
so junky it's just it's just like
falling apart it's not good it gets me
where I need to go but it's just awful
yeah and I end up looking at cars that
are
like nine rungs above where I should be
looking
right have you hit the pendulum so far
let me no no
we do get financial aid okay no we don't
have to come up with all the money is
that what you mean no no no I'm talking
about
you're following so I worked in
education for um for two decades okay
private schools public schools private
universities public universities I've
worked in across the gamut okay my kids
have gone to private school and public
schools okay so there is some data
that exist about kids who go to private
school end up with better outcomes
test scores
um ACT scores SAT scores College
admissions and things like that
right I believe with all my guts and
until I see a study that shows me that
I'm wrong which I'll get on the show and
say hey I was wrong I don't think it
exists
I think that's an much more about an
inputs question than an outputs
meaning I agree
uh for those listening
if you live in a community and it's full
of surgeons and you know bajillionaire
businessmen and women who are sitting
their kids in a private school well
you've self-selected into a school and
the school can reject kids or not let
kids in who aren't of certain academic
quality so you get a selected group of
kids who are then of course are going to
go on to have high test scores but that
has very little to do with the with the
education right
um even if you look at Harvard a study
just came out the Harvard grade
inflation everybody can say he's there
now everybody they always make a change
and so you can look and be like man
Harvard puts out only people who have
four O's no they don't they just give
everybody A's right the community
college class in rural Oklahoma who
takes a kid who can't read and then
gives that kid some skills to go get a
job that's I mean you see I'm saying so
the institution you're falling prey to
um
you have to give your kid the best if
you really love that kid
right and there's only one best and
that's us and we're 58 000 a year
right from sixth grade oh there are
other ways to get there I agree so
um my wife often reminds me she's the
one who is the K-12 scholar
um she was Dr Delaney long before I was
she's way way smarter than me
um
she reminds me often
John did we go to college yes
do we read to our kids yes
do we have books in our house yes do we
all have dinner at uh table regularly
yes our kids are going to be fine
those are the data points okay now when
you get to college prep and all that
that's a whole thing I went to an
incredible Public High School in Houston
and I was very prepared for college so
it does matter
um
is there something deeper here is this
purely academic so you worried about the
social stuff or are you worried about
that kind of drama
yeah pretty much like there's already
been some talk of Lily lives in a little
house we don't live in a little house
but you know like what is and then
she'll ask me questions like why can't
we have an SUV why do we have to drive a
little car like you know things like
that that can she can internalize and
take that into her future and I don't
want to do that to her
I grew up
um
a poor kid in a very affluent community
and I consider that one of the greatest
privileges of my life even though it was
awful and I have a lot of trauma on
scars from it
oh no okay uh and here's what here's
here's where the trauma and scars come
from we didn't talk about it
okay
that's where and so when you don't talk
about stuff they become secrets and
secrets feed shame
and shame is something's wrong with me
because our house is too small
something's wrong with me because we
only have two I only have two pair of
shoes
I only have one jacket or code
great see what I'm saying that's
different then no this is how we choose
to do it we're choosing to have us like
the house I live in right now is pretty
small house and I tell my kids like we
intentionally chose a small house I like
all my kids I like everybody in one
little like close to us and we're doing
that there you see and so talking about
no no we're making choices
yeah we could go mortgage our souls and
get a brand new Lexus and pay 1400 a
month why that's dumb it's a
depreciating asset we buy used Camrys
they're awesome yeah and so I'm teaching
my kids to be proud of the choices they
are making and proud of their particular
station
okay does that make sense so we're we're
talking about it my kids have no idea
what kind of resources we have
look you see what I'm saying
yes and I want it that way so
I think this is hard because there are
some really crummy difficult
um Public Schools
they exist
and a 50 or 60 000 a year private school
may not solve your problems
or that may be taking a sledgehammer too
a mosquito
okay
is there an in-between
yeah and there are a lot of options okay
to make that happen yeah have you fallen
prey to if we need to get the best and
if we don't get the best I'm failing my
kid and I'm gonna have to take a second
job and a third job and all that
uh not the best we don't necessarily
have to do the best but we're gonna do
better than what we have locally okay I
think I think we're committed to that
okay
um
here's my big picture my kids go to uh
Public School
if when I'm on the Internet it's on
social media which
it's not a ton
nothing gets more pushback than when I
tell people that my kids go to the
public schools and so I'm going to make
this super clear I want my kids
exposed to nutty ideas
I want my kids exposed to whackadoo
people
with strange ways of doing the world
I want them exposed to that while they
still live in my house
because they're gonna get exposed to
that in college they're going to get
exposed to that in the workplace they're
going to get exposed to that ever you
cannot live your life now I don't want
my kids exposed to violence I don't want
my kids exposed to terrible teachers and
awful administrators which sounds like
that's where you are who just are not
academically challenging at all I don't
want that yeah absolutely
um but it's my job to teach my kids
spirituality it's my job to teach my kid
community and resilience and how to come
back from heart of things my kids have
had teachers that weren't great
and God can you imagine being having Dr
deloni and Dr deloni with three
doctorates in education coming and
sitting down and staring across me and
you're a third year teacher I mean it's
not even fair so we try to be nice my
wife and I but like there's been some
teachers that weren't great and so we
got to teach my son you're gonna have a
boss that's not great or you're gonna
have a client that's not great and
they're gonna be really tough to work
with here's how you you're right here's
how you persevere and so I think there's
some metal lessons there that are so
good I'm not Outsourcing that stuff
that's my job
yeah
and I there is a balance but I'm I'm
going right through the middle of it I'm
going right through the middle of it
um
I I would not worry if you do go to
private school I would not worry about
your kid being the whatever kid in fact
I would celebrate their friends parents
does that make sense
yeah
um yeah like so-and-so's Dad is a
surgeon man he cuts open people's heads
for a living his mom replaces Hearts she
makes so much money they take care of
them like I I mean I would celebrate it
right
yeah we're gonna do that
you see what I'm saying like just hold
it really open yeah this is who we are
This Is How We Roll can I ask you one
personal question
absolutely do you feel less than
no actually no I don't I I work with a
lot of the people that she goes to
school with the parents of the children
and
um they treat me really well
um we've yeah we're good so you don't
feel like if you accept financial aid
that you're some kind of Charity case
and that you're some kind of
no no no this is um part of part of our
family's Journey okay because your kids
your kids will absorb that
okay and I want you to be really proud
of the choices you're making for your
kid whatever your choices happen to be
and by the way I don't hate on private
schools
um if there's a great private school and
we my wife and I chose to use our
resources that way we'd definitely do
that
um one of my kids may end up in a
private school someday but I don't have
any any
uh ill will towards them at all
um I just hear some of the reasons
people choose to go and I it just sounds
nonsensical what you're saying is really
powerful I think
you're concerned about your kids grades
all right or what your kids will learn
right
um I do think that matters I think
that's important and if you're going to
school and they're they're just sitting
you on Khan Academy or telling you to
watch online videos something that's not
teaching and it's not learning you need
some engagement with real humans who are
walking thing walking you through things
and again that's not opinion that's just
from the data
um
your kid's gonna be your kid and your
kid is going to absorb the lessons they
get from you there's gonna be bullies
everywhere and there's going to be more
on kids everywhere and there's going to
be
the rich kid and the super poor kid
everywhere
kids desperately need their parents to
be anchored in number one together Mom
and Dad together and they need to be
anchored into a set of values is who we
are we choose to drive used to cars we
choose to live in a smaller house we
choose to live in a huge house this is
how we choose to do it we have extra
bedrooms anybody can come stay with us
whenever they need a place to come visit
we choose to have a lake house so that
we can go hang out whatever your life is
own it
don't let your kids absorb your shame or
let themselves feel less than oh
good for you Julie for loving your kids
thinking it through carefully
um I would say there's another option
before you mortgage everything
and if you do end up going that route go
for it stand tall
your kid's gonna do great we'll be right
back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's only your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we're back and for those six
or seven people who are still listening
after we talked about private schools
and vaccines
Kelly has decided the song of the day is
from one of my favorites Johnny Cash one
of my favorite favorite favorites
the song's in honor of her flooded out
home I'm so sorry man happy New Year
happy New Year and merry Christmas
yeah
I think there's no way you're at church
oh it really was there's no way but my
husband did laugh that so while we were
at church the Cowboys beat the Eagles
which no one thought would happen right
and my husband later said that was God
giving me this little thing and saying
enjoy this because in about an hour nope
and God y'all were on your cell phone
during church that's what he smoted you
for I was not on my cell phone during
church oh my gosh thank you very much
yes you were unbelievable the song's
called five feet high
and rising and this is not about Kelly's
drugs song goes like this
my mama always taught me that good
things come from adversity if we put our
faith in the Lord we couldn't see much
good in the flood waters when they were
causing us to leave home but when the
water went down we found that it had
washed a load of rich black bottom dirt
across our land the following year we
had the best crop we'd ever had I
remember hearing how high is the water
mama two feet high and Rising haha is
the water Papa
two feet high in Rising
foreign Kelly
[Music]
12 feet high in Rising
oh man happy New Year everybody will
[Music]